brady singer has faced the tigers more
than any other team in his short big
league career
at second john tumpain at third and the
first pitch is rolled out to second base
and alberto
comes in from the grass and that is a
great start
for brady singer three consecutive extra
base hits
in the fourth inning but otherwise was
sharp
and that's a walk in a well-earned walk
by the rookie badou
so he'll be on with one out would call
more if he felt comfortable
throwing him out going and runner is out
damn gallagher guns down akeel badou for
the second out
pitch coming get him here
another chance for alberto and the
tigers
are scoreless in the first and the
royals will be facing the hard throwing
left-hander tarik school who's
really gaining confidence as he goes
along
the 1-0 to whitmer field got under it
and skies it to left center field
grossman
puts it away for one out
that ball was smoked man
so that will be hard hit at bat number
106.
[Applause]
the payoff to solaire and it blows it
right by him his first strikeout
of the day ends the first in kansas city
we are scoreless on valley sports
that's into center for a base hit
another good piece of hitting from
jonathan scobe he just keeps on keeping
on
against brady singer castro strokes one
down the left field line and that's a
fair ball
it gets by merrifield into the corner it
bounces around
scope is going to be held at third
harold castro has himself a double
yeah just a fastball down and in
in inside outed by harold castro nice
little piece of hitting right here
just drops it down the left field line
and
i think this is a good move by chip hale
right here holding up jonathan scope
that slider was out over the plate and
santana for a moment it looked like
he caught it on the fly but he got it on
a short up
and goodrum strikes out
to the middle answer alberto is there
and
brady singer works around second and
third
and nobody out he's two for five months
he is with one homer against scooble in
his career
welcome back at alberto monteci
just like that brady singer gets out of
a
second and third jam with nobody out
takes care of it himself and
modesty gives him the lead welcome back
is right partner i'll tell you they
missed him in a worse way
make him now three for six with two
homers off school
what a nice welcome back for a young
star
and fastball he challenged him he just
dropped the head right on him good
backspin easy follow through and he knew
it fun at bat
by both participants and it came out in
the tigers favor
uses three pitches to strike out taylor
here to end the second
it's one nothing kansas city this one
did not appear in the postseason that
year
brady singer picks up another strikeout
akil badu
worked a walk his first time up and then
he was caught stealing and that's
right on the line badou's helmet comes
flying off as he goes into second base
with a two out double
another three two lace to right center
but due's going to score we are tied
thanks to de jamer candelario
out of the box trying to get to second
and he's in there safely
an rbi double from jamer candelario
some guys to unlearn that that's right
alberto with the shift
and the inning is over so with two outs
the tigers get back-to-back doubles and
they tie the game
chop to the left side and a do or die
play
castro did the hard part that was
getting the ball in his glove and then
lost it in transition
and santana has a two-out infield single
now the battle will be salvador perez
and salvi smoked a line drive to left
field for a single his first time up off
of scuba
now salvi hits it high and deep to left
field
grossman is back gone for a two-run home
run
leave it to salvador perez to clean it
up and get that lead back
what a nice beautiful shot his 17th
homer
of the year he gets under the high
arcing shot
slight breeze might have helped it as
high as it went look at how under
control he was he didn't over stride
great balance
standing straight up and he ran grossman
into the wall and over it
and it is going to be carlos hernandez
in the fourth
he's a chevy call to the bullpen well i
wasn't expecting to see him
this early but look he's a good strong
power arm he's got four nice pitches
he looks every single time so he's still
excited by that hunger but he's more
excited
by that strikeout right there feeling
very comfortable at the big league level
at 91.92 line drive center field taylor
went for a slide and he missed and
that's going to roll
all the way to the wall whit picks it up
and mazzara is going to end up at
third base with one out oh no
hit him so that's a break yep for a
couple of reasons
the run will not score and now there's a
chance for a double play
100 compared to 70 percent
right at the bag did monday make the tag
he did
no tag runner out of the baseline
is the call by sean barber took over in
the fourth
right center field and sinking and down
so hanser has a hard hit ball for an out
and a bloop for a hit
shortening his swing
to the right side and no play at second
no play at first
scope had two guys standing at second
base ready for a throw
[Applause]
and he got him with a fastball so
scooble has given witt
a bad time in the royals strand two in
the fourth
and that is ball four willy castro
stands in
with a runner on first and nobody down
here's the 3-2
a drive to right center field that
ball's deep that ball is
gone away willie willie castro with a
two-run
shot to tie it up at three julie castro
staying hot gets a breaking ball that's
up center cut right there down the
middle of the plate
has that good stays back on it very well
and this ball goes a long way and that's
the second home run
of the series they were letting it go
a line drive to center and robbie
grossman is aboard for the first time
today
the 2-1 to badou a bullet to right
robbie grossman will go first to third
the tigers aren't done yet here in the
seventh they've already tied it at two
and now they've got runners at the
corners
with only one away oh and it gets by
gallagher and grossman's gonna score the
tigers take the lead
giving up just three runs and striking
out nine
gallagher grounds it out to first and it
gets by scope
that'll be an error and the royals have
their lead-off man on in the bottom of
the seventh
and whit grounds it left side and that's
going to be into left field
so the royals have had some good fortune
in this inning ground balls
off of fielder's gloves
[Applause]
out over the plate and grounded to third
and the tigers
will turn a double play
[Applause]
a flare to right center and that'll drop
a one out single
for nico goodroom here in the tigers
eighth now the 1-1
slice to right good piece of hitting
from willy castro another hit
and another chance for the tigers go
first to third suggest being received by
the players
gets away from gallagher goodroom's head
first slide gets him in there safely to
make it 5-3
now the 2-2 got him looking that's all
right tigers add another in the eighth
the lead is two
and now walks here in the ninth
on the ground and through the left side
for a base hit
and now the 1-1 that one is a shot
just past a diving hands for alberto
taylor cuts it off but not in time to
get candelario who scampers home
and allows jonathan scope to go all the
way to third
no mar mazzara has an rbi single and
it's a 6-3
tigers lead means here's michael former
in the ninth he'll face
the seven eight nine hitters
there's a good start for the royals now
they need at least
one more base runner for a chance
grounded fair so the royals will get a
run
whit goes into scoring position and the
tying run will come up
and he will come to the plate so the
tying run is on and the winning run is
coming to the plate
there he goes here's the o2 swung out of
this boy michael
and he strikes out perez on three
pitches to end it
and the tigers sweep the royals thanks
to a
6-5 win at kauffman stadium